continue également de suivre les
conséquences de la destruction du
barrage de kakovka il y a beaucoup
d'incertitudes et d'inquiétudes
notamment pour la centrale nucléaire de
zapporja car l'eau est nécessaire pour
refroidir les réacteurs d'ailleurs le
chef de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique est attendue sur
place ce mardi l'eau du barrage qui
commence aussi à manquer pour les
habitants de Nico Paul désormais
contraint au système D comme de
l'explique notre envoi spéciale Gulliver
crag
derrière moi des habitants de nico-paul
qui font la queue pour obtenir de l'eau
les badges vides régulièrement mais puis
sont remplis par des camions de
livraison il n'y a plus d'eau dans les
robinets depuis deux jours parce que le
niveau dont l'ex réservoir de carouka
est descendu bien en dessous du niveau
des tuyaux
on essaye le personnel de la compagnie
des
eaux connectés la maison de ses pas on
espère juste que ce sera possible
chez moi on avait déjà plus de gaz et
maintenant l'eau est coupée aussi c'est
merveilleux n'est-ce pas quand j'ai su
qu'il allait y avoir des problèmes avec
l'eau je me suis fait un petit stock
d'eau potable et d'eau non potable cela
a suffi pour 4 jours en économisant et
là c'est la première fois que je viens
prendre de l'eau au point de
distribution
le meilleur brief les journalistes sur
la situation le visage fermé
cela dépasse la compréhension qu'une
chose pareille puisse se produire qui
pourrait venir à l'esprit de quelqu'un
de faire cela de détruire un réservoir
dont toutes les communes limitrophes
dépendaient pour leur approvisionnement
en eau s'il n'y a pas de réservoir il
n'y a pas d'eau
pendant ce temps les nouvelles du front
sont mixtes et difficiles à confirmer on
sait qu'il y a des batailles intenses
sur d'autres parties de la ligne de
front aussi
sont toutefois avoir des informations
vérifiables sur des avancées ou des
pertes des Ukrainiens mais tout le monde
sait que les avancées dans cette
contre-offensive viendront avec un coût
très élevé et il y a une ambiance
quelque peu tendue dans le pays à cause
de cela